hi
this is science hangout from my science
mission so I'm so - up high so we have
today dr. it almost a ski with us
so he is a associate professor at
Harvard Medical School and he has a
several articles very seminal
publications in different journals so it
has won several awards in 2017 he won
Gremio resist award for international
cooperation from Ministry of Science
Argentina he was avoided Laura Schwartz
endowed chair in oncology from Harvard
Medical School the foundation prize on
excellency in hematology oncology
research in 2012 he won mg a tv-set
scholar award 2011 honorary kashkaval
from government of recommen Argentina
and he won several awards in 2009 8 the
list goes on and on and on so I think I
have to stay here forever to say all
these awards anyways so let me introduce
dr. MacLeod ski at much-loved ski
welcome to science hangout thank you so
just to start with just tell us about
yourself rather than me introducing you
more it's better to get from yourself so
go ahead and talk about yourself so I
study medicine emergency I have from
Argentina in the north of Argentina I
study in medical school when I was
finishing medical school I decided I
wanted to do research I was very curious
about understand you make essentially I
didn't feel that I was getting more
understanding of the mechanism by doing
medical school so I decided to go for a
PhD
I went on to Israel already a PhD in
molecular biology the Hebrew University
of Jerusalem and then moved to the
States
I moved to the States for for my
postdoctoral fellowships I was at the
Children's Hospital in Boston here in
Boston where I started Steve was working
on immunology and chromatin
accessibility when working on chromatin
we came upon this novel group of
protists constituents and when it's
finishing my poster calls already
heavily involved in trying to understand
the functions of this protein see points
and that was my lab has been doing since
I started and we beam using 100 C tools
all 36 as an interesting point to
understand different biological
processes as I will tell okay so in your
research career do you have any mentor
role models I did actually I was very
fortunate and lucky to have excellent
mentors throughout my career starting on
my PhD I I did my PhD community bye-bye
to people Judith Barry man she's an
immunologist and Howard Caesar he is in
chromatin biology both excellent
excellent scientists and a fantastic
mentor they they really pushed me to try
to understand better to make the right
questions they really motivated me to go
to the lab every day and then I moved to
the state's when I was also fortunate to
be as a postdoc in the laboratory or
adult is how investigators in the Boston
Children's Hospital and amazing
scientists working on basic elemental
mechanisms of the new receptor and again
trail was also an amazing mentor is so
passionate about science every day
coming to the lab was really we came to
try to understand mechanism and I think
from from the three of them
I got fantastic guidance in how to be
myself API in okay and I know you are
busy with all your work research and all
so do you do anything else can you tell
us about your hobbies I do I think that
the scientists who spend so many hours
in the lab every day that if you try to
balance when you are outside the lab if
you don't try to balance them I know I
think it's toxic you do need to try to
balance and I do
I think have a very active life outside
the lab we love travels with my wife and
daughter we travel when we have time and
I like scuba diving so when you travel I
try to go to places where I can scuba
dive wife is a marathoner she runs so
you also find places to travel where she
can run a marathon oh we can go ahead
and track with my wife and find any
places I also play so yeah I try to keep
to keep this old side okay now coming
back to the lab tell us about you MATLAB
your students a little bit briefly about
everything so I come a medium sized lab
with eight people I have four
postdoctoral fellows and free graduate
students so it's very balanced I have
all students and postdocs now I be very
lucky since the start of my lab I got
excellent people to join the lab and I'm
very motivated self-motivated they
always got people that were challenge me
that we have a question that they will
breed and come and we discuss so it's
been a very lab environment since the
beginning of how I keep them motivated I
think they basically I don't think you
can really enforce that in a fair
most of the people that applied to my
lab they come very self-motivated and
they see me they see how much I enjoy
coming to the lab how much I how much
air for I put in the lab how much
passion I put in the lab and I think
this reference this reflects out when a
student or a postdoc see or PR then it's
a fully engage on the work you are doing
they also are motivated I think this
comes naturally I don't think you can
enforce this AIDS I understand someone
that is joining my now I hope you come
really motivated and you think that what
you are doing it's it's amazing work if
you don't feel like that this is not the
right career for you because science is
a career where we exposed to many many
bumps in the road or every experiment at
work ten other experiments done so you
have to be in pathologic an optimist as
I call it because you really need to
grab those few experiments at work I'm
trying to understand the science behind
it because for many days things won't
work so you need to keep trying and
persevere so that's what I tell you when
people join my love you have to be
passionate you have to be persevere and
really have a positive attitude
otherwise will be a very difficult
career choice most are dancing you know
the career like how do you like went on
with developing change this was at a
time where we knew very little about
these students
how many proteins that were identified
in yeast with potential of work as
chromatin modulator using as a cofactor
and molecule nad which is a metabolite
so people immediately realize maybe
because it's using a metabolite
as a cofactor these chromatin factors
will be influencing metabolic decisions
at the level of the chromatin we knew
very little about them
laboratory where we make mouse models to
understand function so rapidly at the
beginning of my postdoc we said ok
anymore to understand called easy-to-use
function let makes mouse models for them
and there were seven Domino's in mammals
nobody eat which one to follow at that
time so I ended up making monster codes
for many of them and it was at the right
time because it was a field that was
exploding many people were interested on
that or lost proteins and we were the
first to make the mouse not work so very
early my postdoc I was already sharing
these reagents with many laboratories
and I think was the right time to be
doing these experiments because it's a
lot of people were interested on these
proteins by the time I moved to my owner
I was already so let's layer let's hear
about your work now please go ahead and
check this right thank you
let me see
it doesn't let me share only the
application it says share this opinion
hold on a second
tell me if this is a this won't work now
how I stop sharing and share again mm
okay doesn't let me share the the
application only I don't know for what
we saw me get different windows yeah I
do have to leave anyway hold on a second
we try to do this by you sharing the
window instead one second let's see this
world
tell me this work is that okay yeah yeah
this looks all right yeah die happy okay
so we try to do it like these so as I
said my laboratory work with this plot
equals zero six it's a unique factor
among the seven mammalian homologs what
since six does is and actually it was me
: and easton they are settlers
it's a enzyme capable of removing acetyl
groups from from proteins and you can
see here in the presentation it's just a
diagram that's one cr6 is present it's
remove this acetyl groups from chromatin
and acetylation increment in usually
it's linked to active marks now when c6
remove those marks you basically compact
chromatin and you repress expressed gene
expression and on the layer right you
can see a Western blot where if you
remove c6 by knocking down some six in
ours you see this massive increase in in
K 56 and canine which are the two
license that still six regulate so what
we identify since success at least on
the assertiveness this was originally
done by different groups that
biochemically show that since it can
remove these marks we were interested in
understanding the biology
what does cr6 regulate in tissues
themselves and can we understand better
the biology by model 1866 levels so what
we did and this is just from a review we
wrote few years ago now that's ten years
of researching c6
it plays many many roles in mutable
systems here I just show a summary of
silica sand east on the Isetta less
control expression of glycolytic genes
affecting glucose metabolism it control
expression of inflammatory signaling
influencing inflammation
leaping metabolic genes influence cancer
by many ways and I will show you example
from our own work etc it's really
multifunctional polyphyletic protein
with multiple biological roles so we
made the Mouse knockouts many years ago
and what the animals develop among other
things the main things this animals
develop is profound hypoglycemia so
consistent with this these proteins
using nad as a cofactor not surprisingly
maybe cr6
knockout animals had this major
metabolic abnormalities what was for us
a surprise that c6 was unique among the
difference in joins developing is very
acute degeneration the animals were born
normally and many erasers but in days
you see that the animals started losing
weight and this on the right here below
this is glucose levels in blood you can
see that in days the glucose goes down
slam it down to a point where every day
23 24 every animal was dying from a coma
hypoglycemia so it was a major severe
phenotype this is severe hypoglycemia
and we really didn't understand at the
time
why lack of this human chromatin factor
gave us this metabolic limited so when I
was starting my own lab here to my
general we decided to title this
question and try to understand why lack
of the six cause this change in glucose
and what we found just to make a long
story short we published these few years
ago what we found was that c6 is a
repressor of glycolytic genes it's it on
multiple metabolic genes particularly
glycolytic kills and it representing fur
and what we found is that actually most
of the cells in your body which are not
rapidly proliferating the presence of c6
put a check a break on these glycolytic
genes so most of the biter
that goes into the cells goes to the
mitochondria to produce ATP through the
Krebs cycle through the TCA cycle and
that's what the most efficient way to
produce ATP and that's what most of the
cells in your body will do so it's easy
lunch - putting a break on these jeans
so you keep normal mitochondria today
now conditions of nutrient stress lovely
because or hypoxia low oxygen where are
they if the TCA cycle cannot function
properly made those cells goes through
what we call it like politics which
since Nix was released from day and I
can show you here I don't have the
invention but basically since six is
removed from proteins and you get a set
elation in these genes basically causing
a switch you start expressing these
glycolytic genes and among them we have
lactate dehydrogenase pyruvate
dehydrogenase kindness the glucose
transporter and you make a switch where
the cells start up taking much more
glucose but producing lactate less
efficient to produce ATP but give the
cells an opportunity to survive and the
reason why the animals were dying was
because few tissues skeletal muscle um
brown fat particularly we're actually up
taking glucose in an uncontrolled manner
so we'll remove this chromatin factor
and constitutively this animals have
uncontrollable take of glucose the
glucose was going down in the blood and
basically the animals were dying because
the brain didn't have enough glucose to
survive so we proved this in normal
cells that was the function of c6 in
normal cells as a critical regulator of
this glycolytic switch depending on how
much their seats was sitting on
chromatin the cells will decide how much
of a part of it will go to the
mitochondria where we stay in the
cytoplasm to produce life when we were
finishing this experiment we realized
that when we remove c6 from the system
we were making these cells
quantitatively glycolytic they were
producing lactate layer in an
uncontrolled manner and this was
independent of the nutrient or
conditions we say sin 6 Maliki was so
dominant indefinite that at the moment
that when we remove sin 6 they didn't
care about the neutral conditions they
start producing lactate because they
didn't have this repressor in the system
so we wonder this phenotype of like
lactate metabolism even in the presence
of oxygen
it's a phenotype that was described many
years ago in cancer cells and this was
described by an amazing scientist called
Otto world would we call this now the
war would affect where cancer cells
basically switch shift towards Adobe
glycolysis and production of lactic even
in the presence of oxygen that's why we
call it I adored glycolysis and this was
precisely the phenotype of c6 deficient
cells so we hypothesized maybe two
months get rid of c6 to acquire an
increase metabolic advantage in other
words maybe six is acting as a tumor
suppressor maybe it's acting as a tumor
suppressor to protect cells from this
like quality switch so we started
exploring this in different models and
few years ago we published a paper
showing that at least in the context of
colon cancer since six has a very robust
tumor suppressor so we made animals that
were conditionally deleted force in six
removes in six specifically named
testing remember the full knockout
died too early from the hypoglycemia so
we couldn't use the full knockout we
develop an animal where we deleted c6
only in the interesting and we cross the
stupid model called the APC mean mouse
model of color an enormous APC mean
alone in the mouse give you only an
enormous never embrace it when we
closest to the c6 anyway we got more
much more tumors
bigger tumors and actually
adenocarcinoma you can see here is
actually this is an invasive
adenocarcinoma so by removing this
chromatin factor we made the tumors
much more aggressive and what was more
interesting and I will move this here
the tumors when we treated with a drug
called dichloro varsity DCA the tumors
were this is a drug that immediately
cornices when we give them to the
animals in drinking waters look here on
the right these two are the panels of
the c6 knockout animals most of the
low-grade was gone all of the high-grade
will completely disappeared so it was
these tourists two things silly six as a
chromatin factor plays a key role in
protecting against this metabolic switch
and when you don't have c6 tumors that
manage twenty minutes in six become
addicted to this glycolytic switch if
you inhibit Lycoris is a tumor cannot
grow okay so that's basically what we
proved in that factor it was the first
demonstration of how a chromatin factor
could modulate this this metabolic
feature of tunes so this was published
some years ago we then decided to ask so
that's basically a summary of that paper
will show that since six is a chromatin
factor when tumors eliminate c6 you
don't need to acquire what is called
second kids and is to essentially that
were deleted for the sixth one though no
activation of oncogenic signaling Russ
Eric because it was enough to get rid of
this factor to acquire this very
aggressive transformation so at that
time we asked two main questions that we
follow the first was how early is this
glycolytic switch established yeah yeah
so the first question was how early is
this play politics which establish is
this a late adaptation of these tumors
but is it something that is acquired
early in the process of transformation
and the second question was are there
other cancers
we are six function as a
tumor-suppressor so first question most
of the people in the field believe that
this is a light adaptation that humans
are grow very big
they started hiding areas of hypoxia
necrosis so you need warmth in biomass
sustained this rapidly proliferating of
highly aggressive tumor so a lot of
really believed this was a later update
we have some data to suggest this is not
a little attention but rather they
barely only one and I will just show you
one of this if you look here on the
right this is colorectal cancer data set
from the NCI very low levels of the
cancer compared to normal tissues and
this is concomitant with a upregulation
of the glycolytic Kings now in Poland
you can look at stages if you look at
the stages in the colon even at stage
one column carcinoma already this
down-regulating succeeds so this told us
that this is not a late adaptational and
suggest you to us that maybe tumors very
early given the process of
transformation we're acquiring this
metabolic feature of the world started
looking at this that this is unpublished
data which we are still working on it
but basically see is that the intestinal
column carcinoma you have very good
models to look all has clearance to show
that they played the precursors of the
nesting are these cells that sit in the
crypt of the nesting cold intestine
institutions is intestinal stem cells at
our mark by a marker called gr5 they sit
on the base of the grid and what hands
clever shows is that if we mutate a PC
this is the same gene I mentioned before
that contrives intestinal tumorigenesis
exclusively in these stem cells you get
full-blown
you know if you do that in the
transitional amplifying cells you get
nothing so really this intestinal sense
intestinal stem cells are the one that
will be if they mutate APC will become
intestinal cancer stem cells and will
drive the finger so we asked
maybe those are cells that are
glycolytic and if you don't grab c6 you
increase glycolysis we increase the
number of these cells and that's why did
the animals end up with more tunas and
we had a perfect system to look because
we have made those animals at where the
cr6 they persevere so we started asking
those questions and we're still working
on this but basically what we see is
first in the absence of seeing six if
you count those intestinal stem cells we
see an increase in the number of the
stem cells and you can see here is a 30%
increase in the number of the stem cells
and we rescue that by inhibiting
glycolysis so these tell us that in the
absence of sixteen don't increase the
number of novels this is dependent like
Allah sees because we need it like
horses with this small drug he says but
the increase in cells goes down now we
could also look there is a way to grow
this simply larger intestinal organic so
you can grow 3d models of the intestine
and the number of organelles he made he
said I don't reflect of the number of
stem cells that you start to the country
and here you can see on the left in
Norman interesting and old analogy you
see the same in the intestine
suggesting that indeed we have
monstrousness but if we do this from an
animal that is already transformed on a
PC then the increase is much more severe
because three-fold increase in the
number of rollers suggesting that the
context of a transformation event
increased glycolysis plays a much more
critical role and we also were able to
rescue these by inhibiting play choruses
with the dichlorovos
like that I'm not showing it here so we
try to prove that indeed these
extensions are more like oolitic try
first using an animal that is a GFP
reporter from the ngo5 cells this is not
a perfect model because energy has two
positive cells are chimera not agree
Rekha - muscle fully activating the
English whistles so you can see some
increasing glycolytic twins here but not
all of the cells so we decided to find a
different model we created one what we
did what we did is we generated a
reporter we are we can in the orgonite
expressed by lentiviral expression a
gene where we had the promoter of this
glycolytic gene called DK one is one of
the genes that were highly irregular
identical with a reporter named cherry
and a second reporter with a market of
the stem cells called all the same form
and when we did the double stay I mean
we got a very interesting surprise so
this like poetic expression you can sit
here read it's not expressed with
difference quantitative as I read it's a
binary effect you come these very few
cells in the organ but are blasting red
and these are actually the stem cells so
you don't have this is a metabolic
change this is not a developmental
marker I was expecting that we will feel
changes in levels which then stem cells
expressing some more but what we
actually see this is an on and off
effect you have very few cells that are
blasting in glycolysis
everything else is silenced so we
decided to connect the eyes this a
little more the intestinal stem cells
ngo5 positive cells are rapidly
proliferating cells you ask why this
unique cells are doing work and we knew
from cancer biology that says that are
rapidly peripheral more work to increase
their valuables
so they can have some extra metabolites
from glucose for biomass production so
algae are five positive sense
that has cleverly described an actually
rapidly current reality that's one
different from adding somatic stem cells
so we said maybe this engine fi+ cells
because they are rapidly proliferating
they require like choruses to maintain
this proliferation so we mentioned to
see are this unique highly glycolytic
cells rapidly proliferating and that's
actually we got another surprise we
stand for a market of proliferation
called ki-67 and we cost enmities PDK
one cherry reporter and we saw basically
mutually exclusive staining cells that
were green was not red and says what
well red was not clear didn't get a
single yellow cell that's for us was a
surprise I said how long have these
highly like oolitic cells but they are
not proliferating and we know the age of
positive cells I've wrapped in the
proliferating so what are these cells
started like Kalitta cannot not
proliferate so we have to go back read
the literature and we realize that
actually in the literature there were
several reports of a precursors of
intestinal stem cells called the +4 stem
cells this +4 cell that sits here in the
creek they are present they don't worry
free and they are critical to regenerate
the stem cells when you have damaged in
the creek so we actually stained to see
and we believe that the cells that word
is highly like oolitic are these qualia
sad cells sitting here and important to
regenerate the creep when you have
damage so we needed for this to develop
an antibody to work in the normal
interesting all I show you was in the
organoids but we couldn't do this
reporter system in and evil in demise so
we develop a good antibody that
recognizes the subject of PDK phosphor
pdh and you can see indeed in the clips
we have this single cell per crypt you
can see it here 1 2 3 4 per creep we
come once and hiding like oddity
same with the immunofluorescence and we
believe this could be the place for self
we confirm that this is not the ngo5 you
can see here we staying with LG are five
I'm forceful pdh and again all the green
cells at all tonight and five are not
staining we predict end of every pdh and
you see the position for blasting here
on red against suggesting that this is a
quiet cell and may be important to
functionally regenerate the intestine
when you have damage to prove that we
turn to an experiment where you can
irradiate the animals so you can here
edit the animals the clip will be wiped
wiped out and the cells that were
generated so you can measure levels of
regeneration by measuring ki-67 of a
marker of proliferation and you can see
in control cells you get a very nice
proliferation but if you treat the
animals with iCloud or acetate so you
really like policies you significantly
limit the ability of the cells to region
suggesting that indeed is highly
glycolytic cells are there to regenerate
it like Allah sees the cells cannot
regenerate and we believed that you
remove since leaks you increase the
number of cells you have a better
ability to regenerate stem cells and
unfortunately one one of those stem
cells acquired a mutation like a PC then
you our favorite tumorigenic phenotype
because you have cells that are already
known to be like quality but not
basically water we are on this project
we believe we identify the unique
population of quiescent intestinal stem
cells that are critically glycolytic we
still don't know why they are glycolytic
is a iesson sense why they benefit from
high glycolysis we still don't know but
having this increasing by colleges if
you have an increasing by courses like
in the absence of patients you may push
self-renewal and have an increased
number of the stem cells by the time you
acquire an APC mutation you are
basically remote
two mods because you start with a
population that is 10 feet
metabolic and that's why we are
basically with this project the second
question can we explore and you know how
much time I have it in few minutes I
will tell you yet but we are interesting
is this really a phenomenon that only
occurs in colon cancer is 3 6 it most
oppressor only in colon cancer or maybe
other tumors also care about serious
things so the one cancer we looked was
pancreatic cancer for multiple reasons
we have data from human samples where we
saw that the same as in colon in
pancreatic tumors we saw cd6
downregulated significantly in many
tumors so we asked leave in pancreatic
cancer which is a tumor that's up today
it's one of the most lethal tumors at
how it is basically no good treatment
for pancreatic cancer
they are extremely aggressive patient
that are diagnosed ninety-five percent
of these patients will be dead in the
next one to two years it has a very low
survival rate we still don't have any
new targeted therapies as we have for
other treatments we thought maybe if we
can understand better biology we could
contribute to try to understand
potential better therapeutics and so we
decided to ask using mouse models again
whether since the acting as the tumor
suppressor from catechins so we cross
animals at with a mouse model of
pancreatic cancer with a their care as
mutations in the past alone or K R as
p53 which is are both tumor models the
carousel on almost never giving full
pancreatic adenocarcinoma the chaos p53
developed tumors with the latency of 25
weeks in most cases when we remove CC
the Animas develop
two equally aggressive pancreatic cancer
very rapidly you can see even in this
model where they already little tumors
we aggressively the animals came down
with this list some of them starting as
early as ten weeks and all of these
tumors many of them have this lung and
liver metastases which you rarely see so
again as we saw in colon cancer since
6:00 here was acting as a very robust
tumor suppressor and when you remove sin
6 those tumors become much more
aggressive so the next question was is
this dependent on like choruses the same
as in colon may be lucky
maybe those too much more world would
more like political that's why with a
well more aggressive now I have to step
back and tell you something
95% of pancreatic tumors are driven by a
mutation in Kira's is the most frequent
imitator
oncogenic in pancreatic cancer and there
were several papers showing that
mutations in Kara's make pancreatic
tumors highly likely T so we were
hesitant we said if these tumors because
of cameras are already glycolytic why
they will care about cell 6
why don't we need to remove 36 if they
are already very high quality but we
have the human data suggesting that
indeed these tumors down regulates in
six and we got these mouse models where
we clearly see the since it is acting as
a tumor suppressor so we decided to
explore we check to see a long story
short I we try to see if these tumors
were more sensitive to glycolytic
limiters the same as we saw in the colon
cancer we treated these animals in this
really drug and we treated cancer lines
that we develop from the animals with
genetically knockdown of some of the
glycolytic genes and we saw no effect so
having or not having C 6 is not change
the sensitivity to glycolysis these
tumors are already glycolytic but taken
out so six didn't May
the more sensitive to glycolytic English
so what was going on why this sells care
about taking us in seeds and the answer
came from stepping back and looking at
the biologists in six as I mentioned
originally it's a chromatin factor it
sits on many genes it's repressed
manages not only control my policy so we
use a system where we did genome while
chromatin immunoprecipitation to the
mark
that seems six recognize 1856 I
mentioned since six they are stated at
page 56 so we took two balls from the
wild-type the knockout animals we did
chips egg for this mark and we look for
genes that were specifically with
increase assassination in the naka and
we came out with a list of hundred and
eighty genes and here is you can see
very nice they compared to wild-type
they increase in the mark the K 56 mark
in one of the chips and the top Jim
there was called in 2080 for us was a
surprise this is actually the mRNA
levels comparing right up tumors with
knockout tumors and you can see a four
to six hundred fold increase in levels
of in 28 week this was a massive
deregulation of this gene so we decided
to explore further
what linked 28 is is a gene that is
expressed very early during development
is what we call an unco fatal protein
expressed only during development you
can actually substitute to mick Yamanaka
factor when you are doing induced
pluripotent stem cells become put in 28
vm you get so it's a really a very
strong driver of stemness and 10 stem
cell signatures fully silenced in
somatic tissues so we investigated may
be since it is important chromatin
factor to repress lynn 28 and in the
context of the pancreas cells if you are
a pancreatic tumor by taking out since
its you the sinus will be repressed in
28 and maybe this is important to drive
an aggressive
it has never been studying the worst you
studies in other cancers liver and colon
showing that reactivation of 28 people
to drive colon cancer in pancreatic
tumor has never been described before so
we look and just to make I am I need to
view this a second because I want to
show you basically what we see is that
if you are a pancreatic cancer line that
have high levels of cr6 meaning into an
ear doesn't play a role if you in
activating 28 you don't care the cells
keep growing but if you are a human
bankrupt itself where c6 is very low
this genetically drives an increasingly
28 and if you knock down Ling 28 the
cells are dead in 24 hours you compare
here the control with the knockdown in
28 and you can see that the control keep
growing the no-cut are fully dead in 24
hours so those human lines that down
regulate c6 become addicted the
increased level in min 28v and if you
leave it in 28 the tumors cannot grow so
lastly the last part we said okay is
this important in human patients so we
did in Morris no chemistry in human
patients and what we found by staining
for rustling 28 and succeeds that
certain percent 30 percent of pancreatic
human adenocarcinoma staying with this
pattern of low C 6 very highly so we
identified a pathway that is
epigenetically driven okay by cell 6
where if we can know that it's
pancreatic tumors have low levels of 6
leaks you can predict that this is a
human that may respond well to
inhibition of Lin 28th now we are
currently collaborating with several
groups
another university to try to develop 28
millimeters because we believe it could
provide and a major benefit due to a
high fraction of patients with
pancreatic cancer and that's basically
where we are with this we publish the
story last year where we show Napoli
since its act as a critical repression
of pancreatic cancer by by modulating
level of less protein called in 2080 now
is there has a very nice example of what
we call epigenetic plasticity okay I
believe cr6 provide a beautiful example
of what is called epigenetic plasticity
because in colon cancer getting rid of
c6 gave this colon tumors and an
advantage metabolic advantage they were
pushing warhoon effect and this guy goes
tumors on advanced pancreatic cancer
they didn't care about that they were
already very glycolytic but by removing
c6 as a chromatin factor they got
something else they got to remember the
repression of another gene being 28 and
that provide those tumors with a unique
advantage so that still as white humors
in general benefit from modulating
chromatin factor they acquire a
plasticity to go whatever that tumor
will benefit from and that's probably
why we keep seeing more and more with
high frequency imitation of chromatin
factors cancer cells it provide a
beautiful example for that so that's
basically summing of what I told you
today this is what we've been doing
we'll be learning a lot of biology by
studying this unique chromatin factors
in 6 and I think we concealed even
happening a lot it was a very startled
starting point by looking at cells which
we are learning about chromatin biology
cancer metabolism and the link between
metabolism an epigenetic so that's
basically where we are and we think Oh
trust me I will just show you these are
basically all the people in my lab that
this work a lot of very talented postdoc
and students are many many many
collaborators
this is just a picture of the people in
mind out here this is basically the now
that's the different people I was
mentioning throughout the presentation
and we disagree I will stop if you have
some questions thank you so much if you
can and if you can entrap yes great it
is a very good presentation I really
enjoyed it
thank you very much I have a couple of
questions so there are other things do
they do the similar thing like thou
shalt love the love now is a chief
diverse a lot in terms of projects I
have now some people working on a
relationship of chromatin and DNA repair
I trained as I said by chromatin
biologist and with questions in DNA
damage helps I have another it's
positive working specifically on novel
chromatin factors that we identify that
are important for repairing DNA double
strand breaks this is one side of the
lab another student is working on
squamous cell carcinoma we found that in
skin cancer these glycolic which is also
very important and we found that you'll
see that also say as a tumor suppressor
in the context of skin cancer I have
another student working on a completely
different story that has nothing to do
with c6 where we look at metabolic
liabilities we took tumor cells we put
them under very stringent nutrient
conditions and we analyze how the tumors
manage to survive on proliferate and
then these extreme nutrient conditions
we have a very interesting story where
we see that in the absence of some major
metabolites like glutamine which tumors
need glutamine to survive we managed to
get tumors to grow completely
independent of glutamine and this is
because they rewire metabolism in a very
unique way that we are following so
we're still asking a different type of
question some related to cancer some not
I have another
supposed of work in a very basic
mechanism of transcription
we found that c6 as a chromatin
deacetylase does not regulate gene
transcription by by sitting on the
promoter but rather working intragenic
ally with the polymerase and we have a
full story when we identify six external
unique pathways of controlling what is
called transcription elongation that's a
very basic project in the lab that's
nothing to lose
cancer transcription transcription so
the lobbyist is very broad we have some
people working on basic questions some
people working on cancer and six it's
been like mutated or anything in the
cancer like we see enemies actually we
found in tumors it's most of the tumors
down regulates in six at the level of
expression but when we look at the TCGA
data say a few years ago we identified a
the mutations in six we went on to prove
that each one of those mutations were
selected for all of them either decrease
the activity or the stability of systems
we publish a small type in cell reports
that you can see those and naturally
this was already out of date a few years
ago I check recently and there are now
more than 70 mutations is privacy seeds
so the list is growing and the more
cancers are sequenced
I believe we will see more and more of
these mutations is it so I think that's
about my question so I really appreciate
thank you very much it's a very
wonderful presentation it's happy to
participate and tell you about our work
yeah so if you have some new stories in
the coming months and all if you want to
talk about it please feel free to shout
out thank you thank you